[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je me semble que nicolas et
pimprenelle font beaucoup de bruit ce
soir j'ai bien l'impression qu'ils sont
en train de se disputer
je descends voir fera patron j'ai peur
qu'ils le fassent des bêtises
mon seul homme propre aux propos des
bananes des appétits alors que se
passe-t-il vous en faites du bruit ou
non quel désordre
c'est cette fille qui en fait non c'est
toi nico je n'ai pas franchi et maman a
dit qu'il faudra celle aux anneaux du
calme si vous arrêtez de vous disputer
je vais vous était d'accord
est ce que tu nous as les deux disques
plus bon
toi du color du range d'orly il y en a
dans tous les coins toi pas preneur du
balai mais moi nounours je vais mettre
de l'ordre dans la cuisine à nous ce
métier nous jette une chanson pour nous
encourager
we all aux autres vols
[Musique]
je me souviens
quoi
enjeu de petits jeux
souvient
de ma petite maman chérie
10 heures
vva
faire les cours
pour ce il y a plus de là
on a pour moi je répondais j'y cours
maman joli haut et vite chaleur jusqu'à
la berge bruit quand j'étudiais masse
rémillard
eu de mandat
euh tu tu abuses hier avec moi je
répondeur jeu
droit de masse truire au camp
bauchau vous le
savoir lire écrire ma soeur emilie a
joué à la mare à boue pendant ce temps
alors je la dre l'a vu ce but a le don
mais je n'oublie pas que ma maman a
toujours été fier de moi
à
oui vraiment bien se conduisit au sel
faire plaisir à sa chute
le mague rang
tu vois là tout temps on retrouve mais
tu sais c'est drôle de ranger la maison
c'est très amusant et du même si tu veux
aux acteurs méthodes et olot d'autrefois
bien apprenait on vasco chez lui que
chez iron man une à nort la nuit ce
qu'ils peuvent te trouve gentil quand
ils le veulent
vous voyez comme c'est facile de mettre
de l'ordre de ranger ses affaires et
d'aider sa maman moi je le dis toujours
ma maman patron chatel un fils exemple '
je le sais mon gros nounours allons en
route
bonne nuit les petits embrasser bien
fort vos parents une faute de bord
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants boussois bosphore
pas qui vous descend tout de suite voir
nicolas et pimprenelle bon l'échelle que
tu es pressé nounours je le veux pas
laisser à ses deux petits garnements le
temps de me préparer une blague on le
gel ce coup ci ils ne vendront pas
patron vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir propos de pantin comportement je
lui dirai que kendor
[Musique]
bonsoir mon petit pas preneur et mon
petit et mon petit outil dont ni fipa
tannerie nounours niko j'adore ton ça ce
tube la mine d'or je vais voir combien
tu vivais alors il dort très beau
[Applaudissements]
faisons pas de bruit pas trop de bosses
enfin la part dieu
l'agent de police hu
outre but de la loi que désiré ou
monsieur le haut ce que je désire
messieurs voilà vous avez une
contravention une contravention
oui monsieur lellouche pourquoi que j'ai
contrat bravo vous avez une
contravention
puisque vous avez garé votre nuage 15 h
stationnement interdit il se veut vous
coûter cher menti car un stationnement
interdits en l'air c'est très très chaud
les avions qui volent tuent à une
contravention nous et vous devez me
payer didier front je n'ai pas tord jo
c'est du propre
bravo monsieur avant votre permis de
conduire
c'est à dire
[Musique]
geniez [ __ ] nicola ho le coquin et moi
qui croyais que c'était un vrai par jean
de police au jeu trop font petits
garnements attendu que je vous attrape
mais nous on est donné tu peux plus rien
offert en échange aux longues les
enfants adorent mais vous vite
bonne nuit plus de risques en bien
j'éteins la lumière de nicolas nancy
bonne nuit
monsieur l'agent de nuit pas preneur à
dom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
accor patrons ont là une contravention
donne le north merci je vais la faire
sauter
par dessus notre nuage
et hop voilà
plus de contraventions vous savez y
faire vous pas trop allons en route
mon fidèle nounours à vos ordres au
profit des patrons
bonne nuit enfants faites de boue re
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants grill calme ce soir
oui je me demande ce que font nicolas et
pas preneur et bien des 100 voire
nounours vous savez patron lorsque les
enfants sont calmes
je n'ose pas trop aller les dérange nous
allons du courage du courage l'ours ton
l'échelle des papas
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont ça regarde
le combat tympans des si on saute le
juge tu sais bien c'est l'histoire du
petit avis tu la connais bonne source
et bien on va te l'a chanté il était un
petit navire
il est est un petit navire qui n'avait
jamais navigué qui avait charge à jamais
la vigueur et où il a entrepris un long
voyage il autres pays alou voyage je la
mets mes méditerranée cela permet
méditerranée aurait aurait
au haut et au bout de cinq à six
semaines
au bout de cinq à six semaines les
vivres aux affaires la route a manqué
les livres pas tarder à manquer oui oh
oui
au loin on tue reuzeau loconte boys au
tirage à la courte paille ou savoie qui
qui qui sera mangé pour savoir qui est
qui qui sera mangé ou et or et le sort
tomba sur le plus jeune le sort tomba
sur la plus jeune c'est dans l'équipe
qu'ils ont mangé ces d'ennui guie guie
guie salle à manger où on est
ollo aux jeunes sauf au revoir boulet
lui
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas là voilà vous êtes
des quotas j'aurais plus optimiste je ne
chante pas c'est vrai ça à la va vite
rejoindre ton patron non on va se
coucher pas seul
intégra pour te faire plaisir à mes
chronos pleine nuit
bonne nuit les petits d'or publie
[Musique]
oh
oh non
allons en route le nours en route ce que
j'ai eus seront pas trop encore un peu
il me manger
mais ils sont quand même bien mignons
ces petits ce que je lisais en route
nord ce que je les ai alors on y va pas
trop mais quand tu voudras mon cher
nounours on roux banni les enfants fêtes
de bourg ont soir les enfants
j'espère que vous avez été sages ils
sont toujours sort pas trop j'espère
bien nounours mais je n'en suis pas sûr
alors tu dis sont bas c'était dur je les
prends 2 shon et la corde à noeuds
nounours et le mot spira confiance
voyons tu sportif ne nous autorise pas
trop je regarde toujours les sports à la
télé alors sois courageux masi
[Musique]
dieu pas trop aux secours ou young seyes
intérieur or ces pauvres nounours il est
encore doublé olam est pas tout mais
petit peu tout ne s'était pas tournage a
dit je ne suis jamais descendue au cifit
me bats tour mais qui sait mais oui
maudite corde à noeuds elle a glissé si
vite qu'elle mike or chez mes deux potes
c'est plutôt toi bien glissé cas bien
fait on va soigner
or elle soigne et me recevait petit je
veux de job peu assis toi ne pousse plus
on va chercher ce qu'ils sont à la peine
maximale mais qui ne pique pas où l'eau
et voilà au long de l année mais
regardez pas
portez plus rien de tout cela on le look
ça courageux ne nous c'est presque fini
la table notre pâte molle au sérieux ça
y est tu peux regarder je veux remonter
la corde ne pas vexer pense mon d'après
pas une sortie regarde c'est pour bosser
pour les tout petits en bavière gros me
gomes da d'une blague est vrai bien plus
tôt sous la table là c'est pas une
blague c'est une surprise il sûr puisque
papa préparer pour trait voyons voir
momères une seule lui frères ouvrent
moche petit seul que je suis content
merci les enfants que votre papa jean
thissen et qu'il a fait ici un énorme ce
que l'epr
revoilà beaulieu et je vais vite l'a
montré au marchand de sable
bonne nuit les petits maninona no sign
on va s'coucher touchait qu'à des grands
avoue patron joe de chevaux nounours a
l'air bien content au patron sauf que le
fun ou le chat elle est magnifique
nounours alors en août
vanier des enfants faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au froid
j'espère que vous avez été sages pas
trop ils ont été sages
j'en suis certain les shows tels sont
les voir tout de suite moins jeunes pop
ont beau vont se voir les petits
costumes histoire quelle histoire quelle
histoire de cornichons
mais je n'ai pas porté mon lit mais ce
droit
voyons un peu quelle histoire voulez
vous je vous raconte celle aux
cornichons ce père quand il est au bord
de la mer ah oui je la connais bien
c'est la corniche on se trouve au bord
de la mer avec son papa et sa maman date
avec il est déjà la maman de cornichons
range ses belles laine de toutes les
couleurs son papa 13 des paniers en
osier et le petit sont sur la plage
vrai que fait si on sait en faire il a
rempli son petit seau d'eau quand tout à
coup il entend une petite voix qui lui
mais oui il voit un agent au fond de son
saut un tout petit poisson de toutes les
couleurs mazières mais cornichons qui
est très gentil remet la girelle dans la
main elle emmène voir sa maison
louis est un échec mais vous la
connaissez mieux que moi cette histoire
il arrive à la maison de la girelle et
celle ci pour le remercier lui donne des
jolies perles gressier cornichons et
racontant il dit au revoir aux petits
poissons mais les perles dans sa poche
pour les donner à sa maman il s'est
pendu
oui il s'est perdu et il marche
longtemps
londres on aimera trouve plus sa roadmap
tuniso papa ni sa maman ni son âme ni
data et ils marchent si longtemps qu'il
s'endort de fatigue
il n'entend pas la musique que son papa
joue pour lui avec sa guitare
voilà ce que c'est de partir de sel mais
oui il ne faut jamais faire comme
cornichons mes enfants c'est très
dangereux on ne sommes plus à lui nous
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
nous allons bouger tout de suite le must
voilà ce qu'ils sont gentils
[Musique]
non nous sommes fauchés
non non ce produit bonne nuit les petits
la jettent annuel à 2 me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui eh bien allez
vite vous coucher on n'y va pas trop en
route mon cher nounours bon et nuit
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants
patron je veux réjouit ce soir nous
allons faire une bonne partie de
cache-cache tu aimes jouer à cache-cache
nounours j'adore son patron je connais
de bottes cachette
j'espère qu'en te retrouveras et que tu
ne me feras pas attend trop longtemps
voyons patron paul 230 mon les chocs et
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on tombe
bonsoir le petit buzz on s'attendait
alors à quel jeu on joue
moi j'ai eu très beau dis que tu vas pas
faire de la cuisine
non nous allons jouer c'est toi qui vas
chercher non c'est moi c'est non non moi
je préfère vous thaçi la coupe metton
mort
ouais y'a chaillet toc toc toc qui fera
pas manquer euros c'est une petite
goutte d'eau
n'entrez pas madame la pluie votre site
m'ennuie allez plutôt d'un jardin à
hausser le chef mme le romarin thym
prenait le chemin non les romarins à des
colloques impossible de nous excitons
pas à moi
toc toc toc il peut sur le coeur c'est
pas paris nice non ces lieux toto un peu
sur blatter toc toc toc
il fait noir kurt au top du bas des
paupières toc toc toc tu fais des
éclairs toc toc
voici le toner vous avez triché
d'accord pas trop j'arrive et voilà au
lieu de faire une bonne partie de
cache-cache voutré et à présent il est
trop tard vous devez aller vous coucher
le moi je veux faire et 2 août et fait
pas maintenant ce mois vous voulez vous
la toge koch soient raisonnables allons
je te promets convergera une autre fois
ce produit lorsque chaîne lance tu sais
même plus besoin de l'or dit lors d'un
enough
bonne nuit petit job et tu es plus fâché
non tête à la lumière oui l'eau j'ai
tout le temps alors nounours et cette
partie de cache cache et des remises
patron un autre jour moi qui avais
tellement envie d'en faire une tu la
feras nounours j'en suis certain
et vous les enfants ne vous disputez
plus vous voyez on ne joue pas quand on
se dispute ce soir ce sera pas trop
bonne nuit les enfants
allez vite vous coucher le fait de bord
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir les enfants
patron je descends tout de suite j'ai
trop envie de retrouver mes deux petits
j'habite nicolas et pimprenelle que tu
es pressé mon bon de nounours oui vas-y
vite mon petit doigt me dit
peux tu ne vas pas t'ennuyer en leur
compagnie c'est vrais chiffres aux
phases une ourse bon cheval
boussois
alors on est pressé de voir son doudou
le son du public oh oui ça jaillit mais
mme joly vous avez fait de très bons
d'essence jeu monsieur 10e c'est le
capitaine jonathan tu connais pas son
histoire
alors on va te la raconter oui je vous
coupe le capitaine jonathan est âgé de
18 ans à turin jour un pélican dans unis
le d'extrême orient
le pélican de jonathan au matin ou un
oeuf blanc et le show epicor lui
ressemblant étonnamment et ce deuxième
pélican à son tour comme la véritable
aimant à l'eau qui en fait autant
cela peut durer très longtemps si on ne
fait pas d'omelette à l'onf et rothen va
attaquer notre histoire
[Musique]
[Rires]
le ferons quand on aura fini de rire tu
viendras nous turbo nommé
[Musique]
vaslui demos pour tous nous non on
aurait mieux fait de rien lui raconte du
tout pu mener un prenait lé petit
nicolas dors bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit et enfants et voici notre
nounours oh oh
alors tu t'es bien amusez vous que lui
sur l'histoire du capitaine jonathan que
tous seront hélico mines en hausse à 3
je veux vous la raconter auront le
public hors europe qui pondent des mains
la racontera tout à leurs noces
bourgi pas trop nui enfin pu voir les
enfants ou non
que se passe-t-il je suis sûr que
nicolas et pimprenelle viennent de faire
une grosse bêtise tu ferais bien aller
voir ça de plus près une hausse toujours
preuve pas trop chiffon ouhlala bah
ouais mon échelle nounours tu n'as pas
beaucoup d'ordres ma petite échelle ou
te caches tu as le téléphone allô allô
[Musique]
bonjour mademoiselle vous désirez on
voudrait monsieur qui collait carreaux
cassez avait crié parce que prenait
laquelle il a fait plonger pas prêt
c'est nicolas en jouant au ballon rond
ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai tout ce qu'il
vous faut
je vous envoie mon meilleur vitrier
totaux on peut entre eux qu'est ce que
c'est le vitrier attrait messieurs les
triais bonsoir je nomme jamais ciel des
triais alors on l'a fait des bêtises tu
es né c'est le carrot cake assez
monsieur nicolas jeter vite ce morceau
de verre s'il vous plaît c'est très
dangereux il ne faut pas toucher du
verre cassé sa coupe et vous pourriez
vous blesser et quand tu te blesses qui
plairont bon c'est pas la tête de
ferreira
[Applaudissements]
là je l'enlève avec un chiffon comme ça
je ne me lève pas
[Musique]
je vois ce que c'est là vous ne pouvez
plus vous blesser encore un carreau
cassé la vitre du la détenue la vitrine
qui passe la tenue des vitriers l'amitié
basse et 1
et voilà le dernier morceau plaint
d'être la vitrine et la distribuer qui
pas là d'étriller pour la vie triées
lavées triées bassée
merci monsieur le mettriez vous avez
fait du très beau travail
doriot ma petite dame d'orient mon petit
monsieur salut salle et les trier
bono est bien fou
on a plus qu'assez revenue la vraie vie
trier pour remplacer le chaos
ouais comme ça on pourra encore le cas
ce money nicolas car bien peu fromelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon petit nicolas j'ai bien peur que si
tu casses un autre carreau il ne passera
plus de vitriers allons mon bon nounours
en route
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher et fuck de pur bonheur
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
alors vous avez bien joué aujourd'hui au
pourquoi soupire tu nounours ceux morin
trop quel rêve
tu veux encore jouer est une fille sam
non mon heure ou mais quel est il se
rêve un bon football mais pas d'eau de
ponte ouf
une pipe fut mon journal mais rien de
plus facile
je suis sûr que nicolas et pimprenelle
ont tout ce qu'il faut pour satisfaire
ton rêve mais oui c'est vrai j'ai cours
bon le seul le vent popopopop bonsoir
les petits pas si vous saviez
quelle journée je suis fatigué fourbu
jeu le corps il va faire comme papa à
l'eau mais doit annoncer mon fauteuil
pour renault fatigué au sel de morricone
la whey elles sont plus jeunes
bon oui elle bouclait ce que je veux
trop de missions
c'est celle de papa je me rends veuille
ou non
mettez pas tout
havas qui prône bouger tout y est ou non
[Musique]
elles sont un peu serrées mais ce que je
suis
guillaume 7è ski fis vous n'avez pas un
petit journal paraza nationale
merci aux je me sens revivre voisions je
n'ai pas mal au mal ouais le patronat
accepte la quatrième semaine de congés
payés chez taylor gigantesque chasse à
l'homme dans les poids de chavin ce
bienfait soldes
bon les programmes de la semaine open
m'intéresse pas j'avais raison les
enfants j'ai toujours la même chose
le groupe continuons ce canal au lit les
enfants la chope met en touche bleue
quel dommage là
bonne nuit cher petit la jette à la
ligne e fait pour eux colony des poneys
d'orbiel nu des enfants
allez vite vous coucher mais auparavant
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette et
de bien vous laver les dents
alors nounours
ton rêve est exaucé aux autres j'ai
passé un moment délicieux
les nouvelles sont bonnes excellent pas
trop je vais avoir droit à une quatrième
semaine de congés payés
c'est parfait nounours allons en route
bonne nuit les enfants fait de beaux re
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir les petits bonsoir mais minet au
patro j'ai une idée qu'est ce que je
peux donner un coup de téléphone mais je
t'en prie nenê allô allô oui c'est moi
qui voulez-vous voir ce soir votre
nounours ou la mère michelle et moi
alors on voit tout le bon et bien je
vous l'envoie relais mon échelle maire
michel aulas mais vite ça chapeau
tu seras père lustucru méchant
[Musique]
l'heure du repas de midi apparaîtra lolo
c'est ma mère micha qui lui a des mots
chat n'est pas perdue vous l'avez nous
on trouvera sur l'air d'être intervenu à
être un long et michel bédu si c'est
pour du bon choix vous aurez sur l'air
du droit des mineurs à hologramme du don
balon nos deux chats la mère michel mais
nous il nous mais nous oui nous nous
sommes croisés
elle était très contente elle m'a dit
qu'elle reviendrait regroupant ou un but
gag
[Musique]
j'étais de bonne nuit
mais [ __ ] à new york venus la mère
michel nuit les enfants allons envoûte
la mère michel au pardon en route ne
nours en rotin ou porto en route pas
trop bonne nuit les petits faites de
bourrin
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis pour soi
j'ai apporté un beau jeu pour jouer avec
nicolas et pimprenelle ce soir ma chère
petite seul oui nounours veut leur
apprendre à jouer aux dames
mais c'est un jeu très difficile dit
suce hulot nos patrons vous verrez c'est
enfantin difficile et pop bonbon aux
propos pro au soir mais petit jamais une
annonce salut salut je le suis pas
militaire mais perdre à moi j'ai
l'habitude des saluts et bien ce soir
les enfants
je vous propose un jeu formidable c'est
quoi ce jeu formida nous allons faire
une partie de jeu de dames comment ça
non non ça va pas dans ta grosse tête
nicolas parce que tu parlais mal oui
alors enfin nounours the dome c'est un
jeu pour les dom moi je suis un homme du
color beaucoup de messieurs très milan
joue aux dames après 8,9 non non et non
moi j'aurais pas ce jeu là c'est un jeu
de fille c'est moi qui commande un
prenait lé je te montre comment on joue
mes pions ce sont les blancs et les
noirs gens en avance 1 avec prudence et
je mange un thumann après trois minutes
aucune importante à toi tu en avance 1
la raie bien
et oui mais moi ma petite pas prenait lé
jeu tu en manges encore un qui sait
qu'ils gagnent mais non celui qui a tout
mangé
[Musique]
c'est affreux
j'avais presque à nu et un à petit un
preux neige
[Musique]
[ __ ] de coeur gros via
à
ma nuit mon icône elle venait petite
soeur pas preneur pas preneur qu'est ce
que j'y vais je ne tricherai plus si la
petit marshall sable mais savait olala
c'est promis je ne tricherai plus jamais
et la prochaine fois pour faire plaisir
à nicolas
nous jouerons un jeu de carte son
bonne nuit les petits
bonne nuit de noces là je te la lumière
bonneuil north
[Musique]
nicolas a raison je n'aime pas les
tricheurs à vous voilà monsieur nounours
vous savez pas trop
oui et je ne suis pas content du tout et
si vous recommencez
je vous tirerait les oreilles je ne
triche le plus job
patron je le jure et bien
en route
bonne nuit les enfants c'est de beaux
rêves
ac 2
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants boffo o o na parole
nounours tu es fatigué il vaut peut être
mieux que tu n'aillent pas voir nicolas
et pimprenelle mois ne pas aller voir
mes amis au nom alors je veux patron ne
te fâche pas nounours c'était pour rire
mes petits-enfants cheville up bon le
seul jeu pour les voir
quant au papa pom pom pom pom boy pour
beaucoup
j'hésitais qu'elle de dia on va faire
une
c'est une excellente idée et moi moi je
lui tire à cuisine pas je vais prendre
les affaires de membres dans sa chambre
sans faire de bruit je reviens
bonsoir mon petit nicolas oh oui et ta
soeur
nicolas aller à la cuisine elle me
prépare quelque chose de bon pas preneur
le coucou jeu violent l est pas elle est
allée à la salle de bains et fait sa
toilette chers petits
elle suit nos consoeurs finaux tous les
soirs je fais ma toile que je me lave
bien le temps qu'est ce que je vois sur
la table ce teint poudré n'est pas aussi
nicolas tu ferais bien d'aller faire sa
toilette je dois faire mais si tu veux
manger un peu de mieux le dire à
personne ça je le fait que le goût tu
nous le bon vous manger toute la mienne
de mes enfants
vous devriez voir où les filles la cour
pas au mode et m'avait exemple vous
donner à mon fils vient mon petit
nicolas un moment fait accompagner au
lit bonsoir monsieur kadhafi
sinon je n'avais plus vous voir ici ou
ou vos pauvres chéris
josy moment vous perdu un sou du mais
les curieux cette maman ça y est et
perso japon où les coquins alors je me
disais bien qu'elle ressemblait beaucoup
à pimprenelle cette map on vous êtes de
petits drôles
ben je vous aime bien quand même surtout
si vous vous endormez tout de suite oui
sepra mines une ourse tu vois on dort
déjà bonne nuit mon petit la jettent à
la lumière
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons les enfants il n'est plus l'heure
de se déguiser ou de faire des farces
il est l'heure d'aller au lit comme
nicolas et pimprenelle et de vide hormis
y patron ils m'ont bien d'attraper comme
d'habitude mon cher nounours et tu es
content oui
je me sens tu es un brave nounours aussi
pour te faire plaisir tout est petit ami
seront très sage ce soir bonne nuit des
enfants bonne nuit
le petit ami fêtes de bourg heures
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis non dolbeau
repos un instant 90
j'explique d'abord à tous les enfants
que ce soir nous n'avons pas le droit de
parler et puis nous allons seulement
chanter locaux 1 2 mois le jeu commence
tout le monde change à toi nous nous
opposerons
allongeant la peur aux plus confiants de
voir
cette recette qu'on attend quand je
l'entends je suis content c'est la fête
ont fait qualifier nous nous à nous
accompagner au monté au jeu bien plus
jolie des jours où courent sur les
chevaux de bois on irait jouer aux
anneaux on regardera les autos on
rencontrera des amis
qui sommes nous aurons deux ans ils nous
l'ont souvent jonché de combien tu sais
que nous menions si je te défie google
après on sera fatigué et
o'hara s'est reposé
tous les jeunes après la dig et en
invitant à se coucher
[Musique]
monsieur nounours tu es bien bon à vous
tous les petits garçons avec les petites
filles aussi nounours tu es gentil tu es
notre aux siens
vous me faites au groupe les ir
alors je vais vous dit
voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adorerais en font et nous tenons à lui
et bonne nuit nuit moi nous nous y quand
tu reviens bientôt jeu super bien ah oui
nous nous revient
bon je veux aux eaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lens que nounours ah vient tout est un
et qu'enfin ils meurent joueur lorsqu'il
remonte sa grande échelle que nous
partons dans le ciel lorsque notre nuage
samba ba prenait lé et nicolas
se tournent chacun de leur côté sur leur
petit oreiller et jeu
à songer à tous les enfants
que la lune fait
et v
et oh
m
non
il y en a qui suce
or doigt d'autres qui ment
de l'ordre à la lune riz en l'air
elle aime bien les enfants je me
de quelle mon conseil est de leur glisse
à l'oreille
[Musique]
que leur dites r on se crée tout bas
vraiment je ne sais pas
mais moi je sais qu'à tous les
je dis bonne nuit bonne
bah
de nuit
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vaud
où